TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hello, and welcome
to "The Developer Show."
This is your TLDR.
We recently
announced the release
of TensorFlow Serving, which is
a high-performance open source
serving system for machine
learning models designed
for production environments
and optimized for tensor flow.
It's ideal for running
multiple models
at large scale that change over
time based on real-world data.
The post has more details
and the GitHub link.
BabyFirst increased
their installs
by 50% across their portfolio
of apps with Google Play
by implementing store
listening experiments
and localizing the store
listing into 10 languages.
Find out how in the latest
Android Developer Story.
It's time for part 40 of
Laurence Moroney's series
on Google Sign-In.
In the latest post, learn how
you can have your users sign
in via your app to authorize
your service for access
to Google APIs such
as Google Drive.
Autotrack for analytics.js
attempts to leverage
as many Google
Analytics features
as possible while requiring
minimal manual implementation.
To start using more of
Google Analytics today,
check out the post.
The Google Cloud Vision
API is now in beta,
and anyone can
submit their images
to understand the contents,
from detecting everyday objects
to reading text within the
image or even identifying
product logos.
You can now diagnose
your problems
in your production apps
faster with updates
to the Google Cloud Debugger.
It lets you inspect the state
of an application at any code
location without stopping
or slowing it down.
And now it has an enhanced
UI, expanded language support,
and debugging from more places.
Custom Machine Types for
Google Compute Engine
lets you create virtual
machines with vCPU and memory
configurations that are
perfect for your workloads.
While in beta,
we've seen customers
save an average of
19% and as much as 50%
on top of our already
market-leading prices.
It's now in general
availability, so check it out.
"Firecasts" is a
new hands-on YouTube
series for Firebase developers.
Tune in each week to
learn how to build
real-time apps on Android,
iOS, and the web with Firebase.
Actually, I know for
a fact that David East
is in Studio B warming up for
his next Firebase screencast.
Shall we drop in on him?
Yeah, I think we should.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID EAST: --schemaless.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Whatcha doing?
DAVID EAST: Uh, just your
traditional warm-ups, you know,
before a screencast.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Will
you show me one?
DAVID EAST: Extraordinary apps.
Extraordinary apps.
The Firebase database
is schemaless.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: 1, 2 3, 4.
1, 2, 3, 4.
DAVID EAST: The Firebase
database is schemaless.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
I stopped by because
we're on "The Dev Show."
See? "Dev Show."
Hi, "Dev Show."
And I was hoping that
you could tell us
a little bit about your
series and a little bit
about Firebase.
Let's start there.
What is Firebase, for
those few people out there
that don't already know?
DAVID EAST: Yeah, well,
if you like to build apps,
it's really cool
because you build
all this great client-side
code, but then you like,
oh, I have to build a server to
do anything really interesting.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: There's all
that, like, infrastructure--
DAVID EAST: Exactly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
--spin-up that you
have to do before you
actually get to your idea.
DAVID EAST: Right.
Before you actually
get to the fun part.
And so Firebase
completely eliminates
that because it's pretty
much a back-end as a service.
So you can just plug into
your Firebase servers.
And then in addition to getting
scalable infrastructure,
you also get sweet
real-time data.
So every time you update
one piece of data in an app,
it automatically pushes that
data down to every other app.
So they just
instantly refresh it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
totally awesome.
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And I think
one of the things that I
love about Firebase the most
is it's so easy to get started.
DAVID EAST: Oh, yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
that's what you're
doing with these
screencasts, is you're
showing, like, here's a few
steps, and you're started.
DAVID EAST: Pretty much, yeah.
Like, when we were showing it
on each and every platform.
So whether you're an Android,
iOS, or web developer,
we are going to come out
with screencasts for each
and every one of those
topics, like how to get
started, how to
do this and that.
And then showing
everyone, like, kind
of combining these patterns
together and seeing,
if you have one app that has to
be on several platforms, hey,
it's pretty easy when
you use Firebase.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you've
got two episodes on Android
already.
DAVID EAST: Right.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What's
coming out in the future?
DAVID EAST: Yeah, I have a third
episode on Android next week.
And then after that,
we're going to be doing
some stuff in the [INAUDIBLE].
So if you're an Angular fan,
we have some stuff on that.
And then also we're gonna
cover iOS afterwards.
So.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
So fully cross-platform.
DAVID EAST: Oh, yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Using the Firebase.
DAVID EAST: That's what we do.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's very cool.
And it comes out every Tuesday?
DAVID EAST: Every Tuesday.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Every Tuesday.
Check it out.
Follow the link below.
Subscribe.
All those things.
Enjoy your warm-ups.
DAVID EAST: All
right, thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'll
get out of your hair.
DAVID EAST: You're welcome
to join me anytime.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: The Firebase
database is schemaless.
That does have a good
ring to it, doesn't it?
If you'd like to have me
sneak up on somebody else
as they're preparing for a
"Dev Byte" or a screencast,
use the hashtag #AskDevShow.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the channel for this show
every week.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]